the world's most dangerous path the
world's most treacherous the world's
most deadly this got all those
descriptors and more this is El Caminito
del rey near Malaga on the southern
coast of Spain and well once this was
the world's most dangerous path for
certainly something very close to it it
was built between 1901 and 1905 by
sailors and prisoners who are either
used to work at height or didn't really
have much of a choice and it was used to
get people between two hydroelectric
power stations and yes apparently there
were hydroelectric power stations in
1900 stayin it surprised me too
it was named El Caminito del Rey the
Kings little pathway if it was walked by
king alfonso xiii but it didn't look
like this back then it was just some
metal hammered into the rock at 45
degrees and then some concrete put on
top of it and maybe there'd be a bit of
a handrail or a safety wire but it was
certainly not safe by modern standards
and over time the path fell into disuse
and fell into disrepair and then just
start to fall apart but that didn't stop
thrill-seekers as the internet and the
web started to spread news of it this
attracted people from all over the world
to come and walk this crumbling but
apparently just about safe walkway and
there are photos all over the web of
2005 in 2006 of people clinging on to
safety wires and walking across very
narrow bits of metal to try to get to
the next bit but that's not what it
looks like now the trouble was people
kept falling to their deaths at the rate
of one every couple of years and
eventually the local government said
well no this is enough we are closing
this which of course just made the
problem worse because now thrill-seekers
wanted to do the most dangerous path in
the world that had been bound so
eventually they found a solution build a
brand new path on top of the ruins of
the old one and build it to 21st century
standards with 21st century technology
there are safety helmets now there are
hand rails as wire there is a guard at
the entrance checking tickets and there
is Wi-Fi and toilets at each end and you
know what it works it's still thrilling
but it's also safe and now there are a
heck of a lot more people who have
access to this incredible site and the
views but online this is still the most
dangerous path in the world you will
still see the old blog posts from the
two
you'll still see the old image sharing
sites and YouTube videos from five years
ago saying oh yeah this is still
dangerous this is still terrifying and
of course non bothers fact-checking
online so oh this still gets forwarded
everywhere but this isn't that dangerous
anymore it used to be as dangerous as
say a base jump it used to attract
thrill-seekers the real adrenaline
junkies and now it attracts tourists who
are ok with hunts and I reckon that's
better even if the clickbait might not
be true anymore a heck of a lot more
people have access to what is an
incredible place
you